[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 des glaces
artisanales s'invite dans l'assiette des
collégiens et collégiens des Yvelines
depuis à peu près un an des glaces
artanales puisqu'elles sont produites
par la société maison Alpes depuis 2012
et pour en parler avec nous je reçois
aujourd'hui Karima Rafik présidente de
la Société maison Alpes
sont situées donc à Trappes depuis 2012
quelle est l'histoire de la société et
pourquoi vouloir s'encrer dans le
département des Yvelines alors donc
l'histoire de la société alors maison
alperelle effectivement PDG de cette
maison depuis 2016
sachant que ça a été un rachat c'est une
entreprise qui existe depuis les années
2000 créée donc le fondateur était
monsieur maman donc mon prédécesseur qui
était déjà ancré dans les Yvelines
pourquoi il a fait ce choix là parce que
c'est une terre qui est riche tout
simplement on a des producteurs mais
exceptionnel donc pour aller chercher
loin ce qu'on a tout près de chez soi et
vous faites partie des glaciers engagés
qu'est-ce que ça signifie quels sont vos
engagements alors les engagements sont
très simples moi quand j'ai repris
l'entreprise j'ai voulu aller encore
plus loin donc mon prédécesseur
fabriquer des glaces donc en bac de
litres 5 uniquement pour les
restaurateurs et j'ai voulu que ce soit
un produit qui soit réellement
accessible à tout ça et c'est comme ça
que j'ai développé donc notamment une
gamme en grande distribution et des
partenariats dont donc enfin que ce soit
avec des restaurants collectifs ou des
cantines donc c'est ce que vous avez dit
là il y a un instant c'est vraiment
accessible à tous c'est votre souhait
justement que les glaces donc des glaces
artisanales on peut toujours se dire que
c'est plus cher finalement que dans les
glaces de grandes surfaces ou les glaces
premier prix là ce que vous souhaitez
c'est vraiment que ça soit accessible au
plus grand nombre exactement
dès le départ ce que j'ai souhaité c'est
que ce soit accessible à tous et que
qui a une traçabilité surtout du produit
donc engagée engagé pourquoi je réponds
à votre question de tout à l'heure c'est
clairement sur la partie circuit court
donc tous les producteurs enfin la
majeure partie de mes producteurs donc
sont dans les Yvelines donc ça j'y suis
assez attachée
et donc et d'avoir vraiment la
traçabilité du produit réellement fait
maison vos produits pardon sont donc
made in Île-de-France voire même pour
aller un peu plus loin mais Dean
Yvelines vous inscrivez vous l'avez dit
dans une logique de circuit court quels
sont justement les producteurs des
Yvelines qui travaillent avec vous dans
la production de vos glaces alors donc
les producteurs donc nous avons la ferme
de Gagnon donc qui a 10 km de la
fabrique donc quart de légitime on
travaille également avec y le montant à
facteur de café donc la Factory qui a
Houdan donc voilà je
fais pas tous les citer mais il y en a
plusieurs effectivement et pour aller
plus loin vous avez signé justement un
partenariat avec ce midi la société de
gestion des cantines des collèges Yves
Linois comment se partenariat pardon
a-t-il pu être mis en place alors ce
personnage a été mis en place
par le Département
donc c'est une histoire assez
en 2019
je suis assez émue parce que c'est
quelque chose qui a vraiment
qui qui
m'a est perturbé à l'époque et ça avait
pas été évident j'ai eu un incendie
criminel donc qui a brûlé toute l'usine
qui était basée à La Verrière si vous
connaissez voilà attrape également et
donc j'avais appelé tout le monde le
département
les mairies pour qu'il puisse me trouver
un local
et donc c'est là où ils ont réellement
connu ben maison alperel la marque
et donc du coup ils sont dit pourquoi
pas aujourd'hui propos parce qu'ils
avaient aussi à coeur de proposer des
produits locaux pour les cantines donc
c'est un partenariat effectivement qui a
commencé il y a un an donc justement
malheureusement qui s'est produit vous
êtes qui du coup nous a fait connaître
vous êtes fait connaître et aujourd'hui
vous permettez donc au collégiens et
collégiennes de manger de goûter
justement un produit local ça vous a
semblé évident de signer ce partenariat
pour aller un petit peu plus loin dans
ce cette logique de circuit court alors
moi je trouve que c'est ça complètement
du sens
et c'est important pour moi aussi de
sensibiliser je suis maman également de
sensibiliser les enfants dès le plus
jeune âge à réellement savoir ce qu'ils
ont dans leur assiette donc la tracer du
du produit
voilà et nous on a une liste assez
simple si enfin généralement qu'on fait
de vos courses regardez les produits la
liste est très longue donc moi ça a
vraiment un produit fait maison donc où
il y a de la du lait de la crème des
œufs du sucre et un peu d'eau voilà tout
simplement aujourd'hui le manger mieux
devient une priorité dans de nombreuses
cantines des établissements scolaires
c'est un souhait à la fois des
établissements scolaires mais surtout
des parents c'est aussi votre souhait de
valoriser à leur à la fois votre
production locale mais également les
producteurs locaux qui travaillent avec
vous effectivement oui oui oui bien sûr
que c'est important de les valoriser
parce que aujourd'hui en fait moi je
transforme et c'est important de
valoriser aussi leur travail parce que
des gens qui sont qui sont passionnés et
qui permettent voilà de d'avoir des des
produits d'exception une glace c'est
assez vaste les goûts et les textures
sont multiples quelle glace sera enfin
son pardon proposé aux collégiens et
collégien yvelinois alors
des gouttes très simples hein donc
aujourd'hui donc il y a trois produits
donc la vanille le chocolat et la fraise
et comment est-ce qu'on fait une glace
justement quels sont les étapes de
production d'une d'une glace alors les
étapes de produits de production d'une
glace donc nous on fabrique vraiment
maison donc c'est vraiment pas la main
je vous prends l'exemple du caramel donc
le caramel donc on le voilà on le fait
vraiment donc à la main les gousses
vanilles sont encore grattés à la main
voilà on met pas de colorant pas d'actif
pas de conservateur donc c'est vraiment
comme quand vous faites la cuisine chez
vous donc c'est du temps la patience et
après donc on laisse vraiment maturer le
produit pour que derrière une longueur
en bouche de 24 à 112 heures et ça c'est
glace donc on avait dit vanille fraise
et chocolat dans les dans les collèges
yvelinois est-ce que les élèves ont pu
avoir de la documentation par exemple
sur votre entreprise pour découvrir
justement votre votre glace comment
elles sont comment ils sont faits oui
oui bien sûr donc il y avait vraiment
c'était ils le font généralement donc
pendant la semaine du mangeant local
donc aujourd'hui on a en livre pas
régulièrement nos glaces j'espère que ça
va arriver et on livre dans 150 collèges
des Yvelines j'espère que le département
aura et la région notamment plus à cœur
de mettre des produits locaux dans
l'assiette voilà des
élèves la sensibilisation des élèves
face aux circuit court et au manger
mieux se fait par un changement dans
leurs assiettes c'est d'ailleurs évident
mais ça passe aussi par la découverte
des producteurs locaux du territoire
est-ce que vous proposez ou avez pour
projet de proposer des visites de votre
atelier de production au collège oui
alors c'est un projet c'est drôle parce
que je suis en train de monter ce projet
donc comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui je suis
chez Métro trap qui m'avait accueilli à
l'époque donc fin 2019 ce qui nous a
permis de pouvoir remonter l'entreprise
en quatre mois mais voilà on a toujours
pas d'usine d'usine propre donc voilà on
a aménagé en quatre mois le labo voilà
on a fait une usine mais toujours dans
les codes de métro il va falloir un
moment donné qu'on qu'on rende leur
locaux et le projet c'est clairement de
créer une ferme urbaine
où on va proposer donc
aux élèves soit des collèges des lycées
ou des écoles de pouvoir venir voilà
visiter l'usine d'ouvrir l'usine ça sera
une vraiment une avant enfin une
avant-première parce que normalement les
usines n'ouvrent pas leur porte nous on
a vraiment rien à cacher et donc du coup
de de clairement leur proposer de
fabriquer eux-mêmes des glaces donc
voilà c'est et je pense que c'est avec
ce côté ludique qu'on va sensibiliser
aussi les plus jeunes donc là vous nous
avez parlé justement donc vous êtes à
Métro trap pour pour l'instant donc
votre projet c'est de trouver d'autres
locaux vous voulez trouver des des
locaux pour enfin dans les Yvelines
rester dans dans le territoire de
préférence oui en tout cas oui c'est sûr
en Île-de-France donc j'espère que je
vais avoir des des propositions de
locaux qui seront adaptés pour nous
permettre de créer cette firmière ben
non petite question sur sur justement
ces produits locaux cette production
locale changer le mode de consommation
des jeunes dans les cantines donc en
leur offrant justement des produits
locaux est-ce que c'est aussi faire deux
des consommateurs responsables des
consommateurs responsables de demain
complètement je vous enfin je vois pas
d'autres manières après c'est vraiment
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'éducation
dans l'éducation goût l'éducation donc
du coup à les sensibiliser aussi au
circuit court à connaître des
producteurs
a réellement aujourd'hui tout simplement
consommer mieux est-ce que vous avez
rapidement un autre projet justement de
au sein de la maison el perell je pense
que le projet de l'infirmière benne en
tout cas on va tout mettre en oeuvre
pour qu'il puisse se concrétiser dans
les donc là c'est un appel aussi
donc ça sera déjà un très grand projet
et donc voilà mais c'est être clairement
et j'espère que ça va aspirer donc
notamment d'autres marques
de toute façon suivre ce projet et puis
pourquoi pas vous vous inviter quand le
projet avancera beaucoup Karima Rafik
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation on
peut retrouver plus d'informations sur
votre site maison alpes.com et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]